elliot page is living his truth
in the new cover story for time magazine
the 34 year old actor
opens up for the first time since coming
out as a transgender man
in december 2020 and shares the response
he's received
since sharing his story quote what i was
anticipating was
a lot of support and love and a massive
amount of hatred and transphobia
that's essentially what happened the
umbrella academy star talks about his
childhood and frequent desire to cut his
hair short
saying he struggled with his gender
identity for decades
i felt like a boy i wanted to be a boy i
would ask my mom if i could be someday
just getting to be who i am is such an
incredible experience and i feel
grateful for it
and you know i'm in a very fortunate
place in my life
after his fame grew thanks to films like
juno and
inception paige says he was struggling
with depression
anxiety and panic attacks quote i just
never recognized myself
for a long time i could not even look at
a photo of myself
one decision paige made to help him feel
more comfortable in his
own skin was to undergo top surgery a
procedure to remove one's breast tissue
when he came out as transgender this
past winter
he was recovering from the surgery quote
it has completely transformed my life
i'm incredibly grateful paige adds that
the procedure was not
only life-changing but life-saving he
also opens up about choosing the name
elliot explaining that he always liked
it
especially after the 80s classic e.t
he even has a tattoo that reads ep
phone home a nod to the iconic film and
his initials
e t home
phone e.t phone
and paige says it was the coronavirus
pandemic that led him to coming to terms
with his gender identity
i had a lot of time on my own to really
focus on things that i think
in so many ways unconsciously i was
avoiding
i was finally able to embrace being
transgender
and letting myself fully become who i am
it's a similar sentiment
paige previously shared with et when he
came out as gay
in 2014. i feel so happy
and i feel so different from how i felt
when i was closeted
and while paige is candid about this
part of his life
he did not discuss his divorce from wife
emma portner
who has been publicly supportive of his
decision to transition
he did however share that they separated
last summer and
officially divorced in early 2021 adding
that they've remained
close friends so what's next for paige
he says he's looking forward to
continuing his acting career now that
he's living his truth
quote i'm really excited to act now that
i'm fully who i am
in this body no matter the challenges
and difficult moments of this
nothing amounts to getting to feel how i
feel now
you